[Music]
[Music]
thank you
um
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and all other manner of people
that by the command of our lord the king
of france
it is strictly prohibited
on pain of death and the loss of
property
for anyone here in the arms
for to carry a sword or dagger
unless he be one who has the express
permission
of our lord the king
each man is to fight
on horseback and on foot
and if a man that pleases him with any
weapon on device of attack
except
for weapons for devices of equal
design or made with charms or spells or
any other thing that is forbidden by god
and holy church to all good christians
if either combatant shall carry on to
the field of battle any arms have been
forged with spells
charms enchantments or any other
evilness
and so shall the male factor be punished
as an enemy of god
or as a traitor
or doesn't matter
tighter tighter
[Music]
uh
uh
nicely
[Music]
let's go
[Applause]
[Music]
i am telling the truth
i want him to answer for what he has
done
the most unspeakable charge has been
brought against you
join this man
do nothing but evil to me
i am innocent of the crime
i request a duel to the death
the accusation is false
what happened to me is wrong
it wasn't lost
one of us has lied
let us let god decide
confess
the last duel where you are only in
theaters october 15th to get zonzil now
you